maszkulin az amelyik betölti ezt a
potenciált tehát hogy az van a feminin
az egy űrt hoz létre egy kérdést tesz
fel a maszkulin pedig betölti ezt az űrt
és válaszol erre a kérdésre és ez ez a
dinamika nagyon érvényes kettőnk között
ugyanis tényleg folyamatosan észreveszel
dolgokat sokkal érzékenyebb vagy mint én
viszont nekem segítenem kell ezt
megfogalmazni hogy mit is vettél
pontosan észre és akkor már az a meg a
megfogalmazás az már egy fél válasz
tehát úgy ahogy ádám az amelyik nevet ad
az állatoknak úgy úgy nekem az én
feladatom az hogy verbálisan
megfogalmazzak dolgokat segítsek és
valójában ez egy érdekes játék kettőnk
között mert dave ramsey mesélte el
nagyon viccesen de amúgy érvényes ez a
mi kapcsolatunkban is hogy a feleségét
mindig elviszi a tárgyalásokra és mert
mert rájött arra hogy ahányszor nem
hallgatott a feleségére minimum 10000
dollárjába került vagy vagy vagy még
többe és és ez tényleg így van tehát a
annyira érdekes dolgokat vettél észre
akár a bizniszvilágbaan akár akár a
családi vonatkozásokban gyerek álan ht
nem is tudták azok a vacsoránál ülők
hogy az a nénike aki ott csendbenek a
feleség
[Zene]